[Applause]
thank you
hannah and thank you very much everybody
for coming tonight
it is going to be a really important
event because the possibility
probability perhaps that jeremy corbyn
will become
the 55th prime minister of this country
the prime minister who'll be in power
on the 300th anniversary of that first
prime minister robert walpole
this is a very serious and real
possibility and that's what we're
debating tonight it is
the motion is about that he's unfit to
be prime minister it's not
about is he a good or a bad leader it is
specifically can you see him walking
into
number 10 and does he have the qualities
that prime ministers require although
frankly looking at the qualities of some
of the 54 who have pretty
predeced would have pred means
predecessors you
worry whether they had many of the
qualities
themselves so we are
going to be debating this jeremy corbyn
is unfit to be prime minister
and the
first speaker for this motion is on my
immediate right ha jacobson
novelist journalist
best known perhaps perhaps for the
finkler question which won him
the 2010 man booker prize
a prominent critic of jeremy corbyn
and in particular his handling of
anti-semitism
in the labour party howard would you
like to be walking up uh as we go
every speaker has a maximum of 10
minutes
howard that is now 9 59.
mr chairman ladies and gentlemen
something tells me you're expecting to
hear me call
jeremy corbyn and anti-semite
there's been a bit about this in the
press and
i well you know
but i'm not going to call him anything
he says
he isn't an anti-semite hamas
says he isn't an anti-semite the white
supremacist
david duke says he isn't an anti-semite
and that's good enough for me
[Applause]
you might think i'm being ironical
ladies and gentlemen i am incapable of
irony
we all know what an anti-semite looks
like he wears jack boots
a swastika armband and he shouts juden
rouse
jeremy corbyn wears a british home
store's vest
under his shirt and is softly spoken
anti-semites accuse jews of killing
jesus
corbyn is an atheist and seems not to
mind whether we did or we didn't
whether that's because jesus was jewish
and killing him meant
one less jew in the world is not for me
to say
and and he doesn't deny the holocaust
mind you he knows a man who does
in fact he knows a surprising number of
men who do
[Applause]
that he denies ever having been in their
company until photographs turn up
of him rubbing noses with them at the
grave sides of mass murderers
offering to show them his belief systems
if they'll show him
theirs gosh they're almost the same size
should come as no surprise you can't
spend your whole life
in the company of blood libelers and
holocaust deniers
and expect to remember them all by name
if i may quote from oscar wilde's
missing play
the self-importance of being jeremy
to associate with one anti-semite you
don't know to be anti-semitic
mr corbyn may be regarded as a
misfortune
to associate with anti-semites on a
regular basis
looks like a predilection
but look when i think of the scoundrels
i've hung around with
i know how easy it is to get people
wrong even when they turn up to meet you
wearing hoods
and holding burning crosses and jeremy
is it okay if i call him jeremy
has never actually been what you could
call observant
take that mural he championed showing
bankers playing monopoly on the naked
backs of the world's oppressed
you and i ladies and gentlemen would
look at those greedy
grasping hooked nose syphilitic
zionistic financiers
and recognize them at once as straight
out of the julius striker
i spy book of jews but so
innocent of anti-semitic character is
caricature
sorry but so innocent of anti-semitic
caricature is jeremy
that he didn't see anything remotely
offensive
i didn't look closely he explained later
how many times does he have to say that
for god's sake
i might have been there but i don't
think i was involved
i don't remember i didn't look closely
if this reminds you of those who live
downwind of the chimneys of
bergen-belsen
claiming never to have smelt anything
out of the ordinary
i say you have suspicious natures corbyn
is a busy man
busy men must take emotional shortcuts
there's an image of a blood-sucking jew
it's identical
to the image of the blood-sucking jew i
already carry in my head
snap
could there i wonder be such a thing as
an in
advertent anti-semite jeremy claims to
be a piece a peacemaker
a peacemaker brings warring parties
together why then do we only
ever see him taking palestinians to tea
could it be that he just can't remember
to ask the israelis
bugger i've forgotten to invite the jews
again
unless perish the thought it isn't peace
he wants after all
but the destruction but the triumph of
those he calls comrades
and the destruction of those he doesn't
according to his supporters jeremy
corbyn doesn't have a racist bone in his
body
just a question but what is a racist
bone and how do you know whether another
person
has one there are 64 bones in the human
arm alone
can one be absolutely certain that
jeremy doesn't feel
even the tiniest twinge of bone ache
somewhere between the scapular and the
humerus
when he sees an alien figure such as i
coming towards him on islington green
carrying the collected speeches of
benjamin disraeli
and humming mahidisha mama
and what are we to make speaking of
corbyn's unconscious of his inability
ever to disavow anti-semitism without
reminding us
of his lifelong opposition to all forms
of racism
which is like answering the question are
you a wife beater
with the assurance that you always buy
the big issue
because an anti because anti-semitism
ladies and gentlemen
isn't quite a racism it's closer to a
superstition
embedded in theology shrouded in
medieval irrationality
updated to suit leftist economics and
exhumed
whenever a single explanation for all
the evils of the world is sought
to talk of anti-semitism as a racism is
a contradiction in terms
for jeremy corbyn since in his eyes jews
are neither downtrodden
nor exploited but are as usual
colonialists and conspirators the very
source and fount of racism themselves
once whole jews to be racist and zionism
a racist endeavor then no anti-semite
can ever be a racist himself and any
definition
that says otherwise must be amended
that's the psychology now the science
corbyn's political life has been
determined by newton's
first law of inertia which states that
an object will stay at rest forever
as long as nothing pushes or pulls on it
in physics that something that might
push or pull it
is another object in motion in socialist
politics
it is a view contradictory to your own
corbyn averts his face whenever he hears
the word jew
and rolls his eyes whenever he is asked
a question
because he fears the chaos otherwise
known as a change of mind
that maintains you from accepting
there's another way
of looking at the world
i will spend my remaining seconds i
don't mean in life
i mean of this speech telling you why it
matters to everyone not just jews that a
man so spiteful
sanctimonious and obdurate should never
be allowed to do to the country what
he's doing to the party
those who revere corbyn see it as a
virtue that he has never changed his
views
mr chairman it is only a virtue to be
faithful to one's views
if those views are worth staying
faithful
to to persist in a small erroneousness
is the mark of a fool
to persist in a great erroneousness is
the mark of a dangerous fool
the ideology in which corbyn has been
pickled for half a century
without worn before it even reached him
it oversaw the death of millions
that the ideologies he opposes have
scarcely done any better
is not an argument for his you don't
have to love the west
to refuse the embraces of those whose
sole ambition
is to blow the west apart especially if
you wish to call yourself a pacifist
this should have been a golden summer
for labour the nightmare that is brexit
the hell that is jacob rees-mogg the
out-of-season
pantomime that is boris johnson from all
these
labor ought to have delivered us but
corbyn did as much as anyone to make
brexit happen
with his feeble non-support for
remaining do you remember that question
how much do you favor staying uh seven
seven and a half seven that was one to
get us to the barricades was it not
ladies and gentlemen
the wrong man ladies and gentlemen the
wrong man
in the wrong time espousing the wrong
causes
i am nothing if not fair people who are
limited in everything
but the pleasure they take in themselves
are ten a penny
in all political parties they haunt the
peripheries
like ghosts of the christmases they
don't believe in past
backing losing causes throwing tea
parties for murderers
and looking saintly mr corbin's
misfortune
was to be lifted from those peripheries
and dumped
haplessly in the center ladies and
gentlemen
not just for our sake but for his
for theirs will someone please have
pity and dump him back
thanks
thank you uh howard for that uh measured
and
calm introductory speech our first
speaker
against the motion is chris williamson
labor mp for derby north
a key ally of jeremy corbyn on the back
benches
described by the new statesman no less
during the 2017 general election
as the most pro jeremy corbyn
candidate in england's most marginal
constituency
this is chris williamson thank you very
much indeed chair
and um i uh unlike the previous speaker
i'm going to try and stick to
the motion and i aim to demonstrate that
jeremy corbyn is indeed
fit to be prime minister but let me
start by thanking intelligence squared
for arranging this event and i must say
that when i joined the labour party as a
19 year old apprentice bricklayer back
in 1976 i never imagined speaking
at such a high brow event anyway i'm
sorry to say that i think howard's
indulging in a complete
mischaracterization of jeremy in my
opinion jeremy corbyn will prove to be
the best
prime minister this country has ever had
just look what he's achieved just look
what he's achieved already
the labour party's membership has more
than tripled
since he was elected leader in fact
labour's membership's considerably
higher
than every other political party
put together but it's not just labour
soaring membership that's impressive
he's restored hope to millions of people
who'd given up on politics and he's
inspired
young people in a way that we've never
seen before
so what's his secret well the truth is
it's pretty straightforward
labor is now offering a real choice
free market economics has failed
millions of british people
and working-class communities have been
hardest hit
thatcher's promise of a shareholding
property owning democracy
was a fantasy but the confidence trick
worked
and delivered substantial electoral
success in fact
thatcherism was so successful that he
gave birth to tony
blair and new labor margaret thatcher
even said that tony blair and new labor
were her greatest achievements because
she said
we forced our opponents to change their
minds
but that left millions of britons
politically homeless
turnout at elections fell while public
cynicism
about politics grew despite the
financial crash ten years ago
much of the political class and the
mainstream media
are still enthralled to neoliberalism
neither are speaking to the needs of the
country
for the last four decades we've seen
rising inequality
but the preceding 34 years when
inequality narrowed
to such an extent that as a 19 year old
apprentice bricklayer
in 1976 i was able to buy my own house
it was a brand new three-bedroom
semi-detached house
backing onto a nice waterfront in a
desirable village eight miles south
of derby and it was only three times my
annual wage
so another world is possible but it
requires political will
that's why corbyn's message that he'll
make a future labor government work for
the many
not the few is resonating just look at
the polls
there's never been an easier time to
campaign for the labour party
most people support the individual
policies that jeremy's promoting
and by way of evidence charles brandreth
went to guilford
the capital of the home counties looking
for secret socialists
and he found plenty he stopped people on
the street
and asked them if they supported things
like higher taxes for peeping people
earning over 150
000 pounds oh yes yes yes yes i support
that regulating the private rented
sector
yes that's a very good idea oh i turn
this ball out ending privatization in
the national health service well
i'm totally with you on that they said
scrapping tuition fees absolutely about
time
and clamping down on tax avoidance yes
we must definitely do that
there was almost universal support for
those policies and then charles
brandreth turned his clipboard around
and said
these are the policies of jeremy corbyn
there is mainstream popular support
therefore
for jeremy's policy the truth is
that deregulation privatization and the
commodification of public services
was disastrous the one-dimensional
obsession with financial services was
wrong-headed too
and the absence of an industrial
strategy has driven
millions into low-paid precarious
employment
working-class kids can't hope to
replicate what i did
as a 19-year-old apprentice our
industrial heartlands have been
abandoned
and people are searching for answers the
post-crash response
has been hopeless and dangerous
qe for example actually exacerbated
inequality
even the right-wing spectator magazine
described it as
the biggest transfer of wealth to the
rich
of any government policy in recent
documented history
but the last eight years of austerity
has generated real resentment
far-right populism is on the rise fueled
by poverty and insecurity
meanwhile the mainstream media
perpetuate the politics of fear
by scapegoating migrants and that's then
used to whip up racism
political centrism offers nothing in
these circumstances
it's just another name the free market
status quo and that
ship has sailed just look at italy
greece and even france
where macron's poll ratings have
plummeted and this is a guy who models
himself
on tony blair so there's no political
salvation in that direction
but corbyn's program for common sense
socialism offers a populist antidote
to the politics of fear in fact jeremy
corbyn's labour party is the only
traditional leftist center party in
europe that's prevented the drift of its
core vote
thanks to jeremy corbyn labour's answer
the demands of those left behind voters
not by scapegoating migrants not by
whipping up racism
and not by moral panics over crime or
foreign enemies
corbyn's labor office something better
class politics is back on the agenda
but let there be no doubt who we're
talking about when we say
for the many not the few because that
may be where some of howard's
anxieties lie labour's taking aim at an
elite
defined by their class perspective and
nothing else
those who speculate on our economy who
avoid paying tax
who profit from privatized utilities
like gas water
electricity and the trains and as for
the debate about the ihra
examples of anti-semitism let me be
clear
one of the reasons this has been a
sticking point for labour is because we
genuinely care about the politics of
anti-racism
and jeremy corbyn yes has been fighting
racism
all his life the debate in labor has
been exclusively about
preserving the right to speak up for
palestinians
and to legitimately criticize the
israeli government
i want to say this there are three
voices in this debate
but we rarely hear from all three first
there are the diverse voices in the
jewish community
many of whom have a strong and very
understandable deep connection
to israel second there's the labour
party
which must write policy in the interests
of the nation
and according to the party's values and
third
there are the palestinian people who
let's be clear
were violently displaced when israel was
established
we cannot and we must not try to hide
this fact
just because we find it distasteful or
uncomfortable
but labour's policy towards israel
palestine conflict
is for a two-state solution it's not an
attempt to reverse history
just like peace in northern ireland in
fact peace where in whatever form
can only be achieved by dialogue so let
me return to the motion at hand
it might seem odd but the 68 year old
jeremy corbyn
has modernized labor making it fit to
overcome the challenges facing the
country
our manifesto last year saw labor's
biggest
increase in vote share since 1945.
over 80 percent of the british public
support regulation
of tax avoiding digital digital text
giants like amazon
google and facebook 80 of the british
public support raising the minimum wage
establishing a publicly owned national
investment bank and borrowing to invest
polls over 55 these policies
represent the new center ground of
british politics
they represent a direction that no other
labour leader was prepared to go before
corbyn
never mind another political party we
live in a country where the wealthiest
10 percent home 900 times more than the
poorest 10 percent
and yet we're the sixth richest country
on the planet how can we let this go on
but let's talk about the man himself
there's so much said about him it's hard
to keep up
apparently he's a terrorist sympathizer
but he's also a pacifist he's a weak
leader but he's also overbearing he's
the leader of a cult but he's not
charismatic
what i see in jeremy every time he
stands at that dispatch box even under
the glare
from both sides of the chamber is a man
with a strength
of moral convictions and yet these
convictions are far from dogmatic
the special thing about jeremy is that
he's a politician that listens
everywhere you go with him is a complete
nightmare he speaks to everyone and i
mean he really speaks and he really
listens
is that not the character of a man
who's fit to government fit to govern
because
what do we mean by governing john
mcdonnell's fond of saying
when labor goes into government we all
go into government
and jeremy is above all a democrat he
wants ordinary people to have a say in
how their
world is shaped isn't that refreshing is
this
not the attitude we need to heal a
nation divided by four decades of
neoliberalism
are made worse by a government that's
inflicted eight years of
counterproductive
austerity people on the left
often say that at times of crisis we
must choose socialism or barbarism
well today we have a similar choice
investment or austerity
dialogue or conflict democracy or dogma
the choice today
is between corbyn's labor or a tory
twilight zone
powerful and passionate from chris
and brilliantly on time you came in just
as that clock
said uh 10 minutes precisely uh anna
subray
is going to speak next for the motion
coming up now
to the podium conservative mp for
brockstowe in nottinghamshire and former
business minister
until 2016 a prominent
critic of jeremy corbyn anna
thinks that jeremy is a hard left
marxist
she's a key member of the people's vote
campaign for a referendum on
the brexit deal anna you have your
10 minutes beginning now well thank you
very much and thank you everybody for
coming along
what i'd like you first of all to do is
to remember when you were back at school
uh whichever school you may have gone to
there's i think it's almost impossible
to imagine that you didn't have a head
teacher and throughout your life
you will have had in your experiences
times when you will have
encountered or it may have been you
yourself who has been
a leader so we have all had experiences
of what we would expect to see in a
leader
a good leader or a bad leader or perhaps
not so great leader
so what are the qualities that make a
great
leader because of course you need to
have those qualities
to be the most important important
leader in our country
which is to be our prime minister i
suggest as you consider that some of the
following qualities
integrity competence
an ability to inspire a dis an ability
to be able to
take decisions and ability to have
accountability in your leadership to
have courage
and most of all perhaps in the political
field as a prime minister
to be successful i listened with care
to chris's speech when he spoke in such
glowing terms
about jeremy corbyn spectacularly
forgetting of course
that last june we had a general election
and whilst it's right that he won a few
more seats
he spectacularly failed because he
lost as leader of the labour party
at a time when arguably it would have
been the most
easiest win of any general election
because of the profound failings of my
party when it went into that campaign
which as you might imagine
i don't intend to dwell upon
but and i really wish you hadn't
applauded
now if you haven't been convinced by the
magnificent speech
of howard over there may i give you some
other
suggestions and ideas as to why jeremy
corbyn
is profoundly unfit to not only be our
prime minister
but to be the leader of one of the most
important political parties in the world
even though it's a party i've obviously
never been a member of i don't subscribe
to and seek to fight
i never left recognize what an important
political
party it is and i know what it has meant
for so many people
in our history and in our country one of
the most
peculiarly awful moments in the time
that i've been in parliament
i was elected in 2010 i'm an old
criminal barrister and i came into
politics or returned quite later on in
my life
we're standing in parliament square just
down the road there
surrounded by members of the jewish
community who were staging a protest
against anti-semitism in their own
party the labour party and i sat
in parliament listening to speeches from
members of parliament who were jewish
who talked about anti-semitism in their
lives
on a scale that they had never
experienced before
but the most remarkable and most
disturbing and distressing speeches
were those from labour jewish mps
who talked about this rise in
anti-semitism
from within their own party
and that is a party that jeremy corbyn
has now led for what is it almost
three it is three years almost
he should be ashamed of what
state he has taken that great political
party
into
and it's it's not just the jewish mps
in the labour party who make complaint
it's the women too
speak to women labor mps about the abuse
that they have received
during his tenure by members of
their party and in particular
the abuse they have suffered by
supporters and from supporters
of jeremy corbyn and howard rightly
mentioned brexit i don't think chris
mentioned it at all
astonishing isn't it the most important
matter issue decision that our country
has taken
since the second world war and as howard
rightly
identified again corbyn spectacularly
failed to lead his party his people his
voters
into making the right decision for our
country
by his not just his lackluster
performance
but that by that 7.5 that he gave
and of course he said that because he
doesn't believe
that we should have stayed and should
remain within the european union
we've heard from chris about the return
of the class struggle
he is the perfect embodiment of what has
happened to the labor party
the return of the old hard
left it's nothing new i remember it from
my days as a student
these are the people who are now back in
charge
these are the people who are running the
labour party
and on brexit this issue that dominates
our politics
what do we see from the labour party
where is the leadership where is the
policies
none of these things exist dragging and
screaming they were
to accept a customs union they still
haven't embraced the merits of the
single market
because perversely and bizarrely from
this great party or
this great leader that chris eulogizes
who apparently
believes in immigration they still won't
come out
and make the positive case for
immigration that must and should be made
i say to their eternal shame they have
shown no leadership
and what does that mean what has that
resulted in this is how i
see it well you could say the official
opposition is a bunch of
tory back benchers like me and some very
brave
moderates on the labour party side as
well who do
our best to put some sanity and reason
into this terrible crisis that our
country will face if we don't get a good
deal
or even better if we were to remain
within the european union but god help
us
if we have that hard brexit what it
means in my opinion
is there are millions and millions of
people in
our country who believe that nobody
speaks for them they are good sensible
moderate tolerant people
who have long occupied the center ground
of british political life
they have seen the labour party been
taken over
by the marxists the trotskyists the
rabble that have existed
on the extremes of politics for a long
time
and chris says these are the people
these hundreds of thousands that
apparently
jeremy has brought back to the labor
party what i think ed miliband would say
it was his three pound membership
that had a bit to do with it that's what
jeremy did he took advantage of that now
i would agree only in this way i think
that corbyn
has inspired a section of our young
people who understandably in my view
were disenchanted
who are ideologic idealistic who wanted
to hear stuff perhaps they hadn't heard
from maine
political classes for far too long and i
i think he caught that mood
i think he wrote that wave and he did it
very well but of course as they now see
what it really means
corbin corbyn's politics as they now see
and understand
the anti-semitism that has always run
through the extreme left i believe they
are quite rightly
turning away so he's apparently
got even more members into the labour
party this is his
it seems only victory and success of
course chris forgets and doesn't tell
you
about the 103 resignations from the
labour front bench
during jeremy corbyn's tenure and you
know that within the labour party as it
exists in parliament
he has very little support amongst
members of his own party who sit in
parliament
and i would uh i would argue that speaks
volumes because
i don't want to play the man i do want
to talk about his policies
but i think the clock's against me but
what i would say is this
on all the big occasions like yesterday
when the prime minister stood up and
talked about what had happened in
salisbury
on all the great occasions corbin
just can't do it he just hasn't got the
ability
to say the sort of thing that you would
expect from a credible leader
of a major political party especially
the leader of the opposition
ian blackford vince cable spoke better
than he did yesterday and even when he
has a superb
open goal and some would say that my
prime minister often
stands in parliament in front of that
very wide
open goal spectacularly on every
occasion
he misses it and why is that
because he is somebody who has always
been
on the absolute fringes carping from the
sidelines
somebody who probably the biggest
decision of his life
was what was going to be the vegetarian
option at the palestinian solidarity
meeting
i make i make light of it but ladies and
gentlemen
in my respectful submissions to you
there really is no debate whichever way
you cut it
this man is not fit to be our prime
minister never mind the leader
of the labour party
so uh thank you very much indeed uh anna
for
uh that i think we we got uh the general
drift there
of what you thought about jeremy corbyn
which after all is the point of the
debate now we're going to have against
the motion and
for jeremy corbyn uh ash
sarkar ash is senior editor
at navarro media which as i'm sure you
know is a left-leaning
online news outlet where her work
focuses on race gender
class and power ash
as you will shortly discover is a
prominent supporter
of jeremy corbyn ash
i'll keep it brief what the [ __ ] are we
all doing here
i don't mean this in any philosophical
sense
real talk what the hell
are we all doing here love island has
finished but
that's still no excuse really to spend
your evening in this way
i mean it's my job to chat crap for a
living but if i'm being honest with you
i really hate these things a slot
up on the stage come here we prowl
around for our allotted 10 minutes given
it the full gordon brown if we are able
telling you that jeremy corbyn is either
the cause of or the solution to
all your life's problems and we
gnaw over the greatest hits brexit
populism foreign policy anti-semitism
civility and then we put it in your
hands
the audience the demos who paid between
15 and 30 quid for the privilege of
voting
and we practice our faces for losing
gracefully we hope that we would be
magnanimous in the event of victory and
then
every single person in this room every
one of us
goes home with a comforting hum
of self-satisfaction for what we have
done
in this room is none other than the
lofty business of politics
itself which is utter
fraff right all we're doing in here or
even just around the corner in the
palace of westminster your place of work
mate
or in broadcasting house is trying to
keep alive
a collective delusion that politics
resides in these approximations of the
oxford union debating society
and that's why jeremy corbyn scares the
bejesus out of so many people
not because he is a czech spy
who moonlights as a member of hezbollah
all while working undercover
for the provisional ira of course while
at the same time
simultaneously trying to do a hard
brexit
and subvert the referendum outcome
it's because corbyn as leader of the
labour party
is an expression of the social forces
poised to change britain on a scale
which it hasn't seen
since 1945 because
at its heart the project of corbinism
is the building of power outside the
hallowed halls of westminster
it's about power in our neighborhoods
in our unions and our workplaces our
schools and our community centers
our social networks both on and offline
i want to speak in this register the
register
of movements i want to speak in my
beven's words
the language of priorities
so hands up full disclosure i am
not a labour party member like you know
what's that saying
about not wanting to be a member of any
club that would have you
in it i go with that my heart is with
movement politics they always have been
it's been that way in my family for
generations
so my grandmother came here at the age
of 17.
she was greeted by teddy boyz spitting
bile at her
my mother similarly would often put her
own
five foot one body in between london's
black and brown
youth and the racist police officers and
or national front members sometimes it
was hard to tell the difference between
them
and neither of them had very much
positive to say
about the labour party and this was in
the age of what anna calls
the old left back in the 70s which
apparently
is the same one that we've got now they
weren't any big fan of this
old left many of the unions were hostile
to black and asians participating in
organizing with them
often the same labour councillors who
are trying to organize
events against the nf would be letting
out their council properties
for the nfts at the same time a gross
act of hypocrisy
in my mum and my grandmother's eyes so
they committed themselves
wholesale to movement politics outside
of the labour party
though funnily enough both my mom
and my grandmother have fond memories of
a certain scruffy haringey councillor
later mp for islington north joining
them on the anti-apartheid picket line
and in my mom's case supporting her
campaign for specialist domestic
violence services for women of color
and it is in their tradition the
tradition of my mom and my grandma
that i am first and foremost an
anti-racist
activist and it is for this reason
that i say unequivocally that we
must fight anti-semitism islamophobia
anti-black racism xenophobia in the
labour party and the left at large
tooth and nail and we cannot
in any way deny the fact that these
issues exist on the left and they exist
on the left because
the left exists in society takes some
specific forms on the left but
it's essentially the same things that we
see elsewhere
and any call by loyalist who's telling
you that we don't have to do
race do anti-racism and the labour party
is missing the whole point of corbyn's
politics
in their entirety he has always been a
dedicated
anti-racist activist and the women of my
family knew something
and i think corbyn in his days as an
activist knew something too
that electoral politics alone cannot
deliver substantial
social change like that anti-racist
change which is so needed in our society
indeed as the slogan goes there is no
justice
there is just us skipping forward a few
decades
we knew this in 2010 i was a student
activist who along with
thousands of others up and down the
country responded to the betrayal of the
liberal democrats and
even woke tories like anna suberey who
trebled the tuition fees by uh
occupying our universities just down the
road on westminster bridge we were
kettled we were
charged out with horses in the freezing
cold and there were only two
mps who came to see us during this time
when we were sleeping on a cold
university floor because
the university administration had cut
off the heating
eating cold hermes which is quite crap
jeremy corbyn
and john mcdonnell and they've never
forgotten
the debt that they owe to these social
movements
they know that when they enter number 10
they're not going to be all that
interested in parliamentary horse
trading
meeting up with their opposite numbers
maybe trying to engineer some kind of
parliamentary split to i don't know
scrap over six percent of the votes like
many centrist mps
instead they will be meeting with people
like disabled people against the cuts
they will be meeting with the families
of people who've lost loved ones
to police violence they will be meeting
with people
directly affected by austerity
and using their voices to guide the
direction of policy
in this country that's social movement
politics
the funny thing about both uh howard and
anna's speeches is that they
acknowledged that the summer should have
really been an open goal for labor
polls haven't shifted very much the
awful depressing thing
about this anti-semitism crisis
is that there's not much cut through to
the rest of the british public
everyone is deeply alienated and turned
off from seeing the serious business of
racism reduced
to a cheap opportunity for political
point scoring
i'm deeply depressed by it i'm deeply
depressed
that for your powerful words against
anti-semitism they were
powerful anna that you've had nothing to
say about the crisis of islamophobia
within your own party
from figures such as baroness varsity
who has called for an inquiry
and has been stonewalled at every turn i
also don't remember a great deal of
criticism of your colleagues like
michael fabricant sharing islamophobic
memes and these memes
are very similar to the form in which
anti-semitism takes i don't agree with
howard that anti-semitism is
divorced from all other kinds of racism
i agree with edward syed who says that
anti-semitism and islamophobia are both
nourished
at the same source nurtured by the same
stream
i as a muslim cannot be safe while my
jewish brothers and sisters
are unsafe and vice versa
so i've got about a minute left i'll
probably end a bit sooner than that
because uh
i think the natives are getting a bit
restless
i don't actually care about jeremy
corbyn's personality i mean i think he's
a nice enough guy it reminds me of the
werther's original granddad
i care about us i care about if
we are ready for government because the
tories they'd rather talk about
personality than policy
because that's the terrain in which they
lose and it's up to
us to keep the conversation on the
issues
that really affect us every day it's not
a question
of whether we trust jeremy corbyn to be
a fit prime minister when he walks into
number 10.
it's about whether we trust ourselves to
walk in behind him
so to paraphrase someone whose name i've
forgotten
after tonight catch up on the programs
that you missed
and then go back into your neighborhoods
and prepare for government
[Applause]
so uh uh ash
passionate also unconventional
uh quiet i thought uh understated
uh beginning um i mean why the [ __ ] are
we here after all um uh
great let's uh begin with just getting
some movement amongst the panel but
before then
i do have the results very hot off the
press from
uh people's democracy and
it is on the motion is in fact
in truth jeremy corbyn unfit to be prime
minister
well apparently 66 percent of you
think he is unfit 13
i think he's just fine and 21
of you undecided so we're going to take
that vote again i didn't go through the
long rigmarole of reminding you the
procedure because most of you
have been here before but we're going to
have another vote and i'm going to read
out
that to see how people have shifted 21
i'm going to say we're going to be
australian here and
say that you can't be undecided you
simply have to have
a view i mean come on why have you come
out here if you can't pick up my mind
whether he's
fit or unfit what are you doing here why
didn't you watch
uh what watch love island because it's
not on but you could see it on
on iplayer or something so you have to
vote and i'm going to want to see
real movement there and okay so let's
just get
howard um i got the point howard uh that
you think jeremy is a bit of an
anti-semite
but why does that make him unfit to be
prime minister
given that most uh of the 54.
absolutely most of the previous prime
ministers
many many previous prime ministers
have been racist well i'll tell you
something between ourselves since no one
is listening
i don't care that much either i don't
care that much
what i care is the lies that he spins
to protect his anti-semitism
what i what i cannot bear is this is a
man
pickled in sanctimony pickled by his
supporters in
even further sentiment with this account
of i've fought racism all my life
what is that worth if the first time
he's brought to brought to a test
here is a problem of racism how does he
cope he bottles it
he looks the other way the whole
description that we've had of corbyn
tonight
is a bit of a person we've never seen
yesterday upon the stair
i met a man who wasn't there he's a man
who isn't
there is he there um
astrid um uh
is he there and is he a liar
is jeremy corbyn a liar see that the
thing is when you say is he there it's
like you're asking me is he there as
some kind of proto-father figure i mean
i think that this idea of
jeremy corbyn as a totem onto which you
project all your hopes or indeed
all your fears or your anxieties or your
kind of bogeymen
is ridiculous is he there as a
principled anti-racist who
has voted in favor of anti-racist policy
when
people on this panel have not who've
stood by migrants
who've stood by people who've been
victims of police violence he's done all
those things
that is a matter of fact and record do i
think the labour party's been quick
enough
to respond to the anti-semitism crisis i
think there's been a great deal of
bureaucratic inertia
but i don't think that any other parties
have done much better when tackling the
worst problems
in their own circles okay uh chris is he
a liar because i would note uh the not
telling lies is an absolutely necessary
requirement for not being prime minister
well jeremy
well look jeremy is absolutely straight
as a die and
uh you know the the the notion of uh
straight talking honest politics which
was the strap line
in his leadership campaign goes to the
very heart of jeremy corbyn
absolutely and indeed you know he is an
anti-racist he has stood up to all forms
of racism including anti-semitism and
what i get
pretty annoyed about is how people
conflate
appalling anti-semitic abuse online
with labour party members and somehow
hold jeremy corbyn responsible the truth
is the labour party has done more than
any political party to address
anti-semitism far more than the
conservative policy
and the conservative party is riddled
with
racism and where is anna as
ash was pointing out where is anna in
actually standing up to
that i'm afraid she's absent without
leave so there's a couple of points to
be taken up there
first of all as a long i was in the
anti-nazi league
before ash was even born so i've been
fighting racism all my life
secondly sec hang on i didn't interrupt
you
secondly i don't disagree the
there are bound to be racists in the
conservative party
but we're talking about the labour party
where there has been
a rise in anti-semitism
under germany
and you say no that's true and you
say rubbish and i didn't interrupt you
either mr williamson
okay and we're not just gonna talk
jewish mps
who suffer anti-semitism from labor
party members
okay chris well
there's been research on this and enough
and it's demonstrated that
anti-semitism in the labor movement
is actually lower than the country at
large and furthermore
anti-semitism within the labour movement
and labor supporters has actually
reduced
since jeremy corbyn became the leader so
for anna to
for anna well i'm sorry well look at the
research
look at the research don't be blinkered
okay um okay now uh clearly
our critter the audience uh clearly the
audience is strongly agreeing with that
anna uh moving on from that one is your
party
anti-islamic certainly not uh
are there no anti-islamic people in the
party i'm sure there are as there are in
all parties because parties reflect
unfortunately
our society look i'm the co-chair of the
appg
on for muslims british muslims one of
the things that we are looking at
is the definition of islamophobia so
that we now move to putting that into
law so islamophobia of course is a
problem in our society
and frankly i think it's grown since
we've had the referendum i think
intolerance and racism actually has
grown unfortunately in our country this
is the referee
that's why we all need to come together
and fight it
together i'm going to ask you a question
now about
europe you have a choice i'm going to
give you a choice of two visions
you can either have britain still in
europe
and there's a second referendum and we
vote to remain in or
going with that is jeremy corbyn at
number 10. would you sooner be
in europe still with jeremy corbyn which
would you sooner
i've actually thought about this okay
good while you're carrying on thinking
about it no i've got an answer
the thing is i don't want us to leave
the european union but if we leave the
european union
at least we can go back we won't go back
on such good terms
but we can go back might take my
daughter's generation to do it
but we can go back if you get jeremy
corbyn
into number 10 god help our country and
you won't be able to get rid of him
for five years and the damage he will do
will be
even greater well uh let's take
that very point because chris you
mentioned yourself
that he's 68 in fact he's 69 that means
he might not be
73 until he goes in and uh that means he
might not be 78 who comes out 83
after another term i mean even gladstone
is only 82 in churchill
80. i mean that's getting on a bit isn't
it we're talking about fitness
uh here uh is he gonna be fit i mean
some people would say he's very fit now
but would he still be fit in office
at that age of course you will and let's
remember the 60 is the new 30 for a
start
and jeremy corbyn is also bordering on a
vegan and the vegans are going to
inherit the earth so he's incredibly
healthy i don't think he drinks very
much and he
is driven to actually create a better
country absolutely so yes of course
he'll be fit enough
and he's got the energy indeed angela
eagle said i don't know how he does it
during the
referendum campaign he has the energy of
a 25 year old jeremy corbyn did more
than any leader of any political party
to secure a remain vote
and he was absolutely right he was
absolutely right when he said
when he gave the european union seven
out of ten
because i tell you what the reason why
the british people voted against
the european union voted to come out was
because of the policies
of the people like anna subrie because
she's had abundant whole swathes
of our industrial heartland into an
abandoned working-class
communities and they were sick to the
back teeth of it
and they wanted something different now
i think they were misplaced their view
but that was the problem it was
absolutely not down to jeremy corbyn and
as i say
straight talking on his politics jeremy
tells it
how he sees it and he felt
seven out of ten was the appropriate
score to give your opinion so he gave an
honest answer and he's been pilloried
for telling the truth
yeah thank you very much indeed we're
just coming on to questions
now so let's have the lights up and
we're going to just see
uh there i wanted to get a moment of
quiet consensus
between uh both sides before we went in
till we achieved that
uh here um and we're going to have the
first question
there is a lady uh in the front row i
want to see a second
question i want to go over on this side
at the back yes
somebody over there is going to take the
second question please
right this debate was about whether
jeremy corbyn is
fit or unfit to be prime minister it has
revolved an awful lot around
anti-semitism
two things why is my synagogue
in the center of london jewish new year
having to put up the sort of entrances
that normally we see
in airports we've never had that before
and the increase in attacks on jewish
people has risen with jeremy corbyn
and if jeremy corbyn is so wonderful why
are you not streaks ahead in the point
and why when he adopts
the official definition of ant of
anti-semitism
does he have to put a caveat on it okay
so there's
uh you've spoken too much panel
about anti-semitism but there blow me
down to a question on anti-semitism
question number two over there please
stand by question number three
yes come in too uh chris you said that
jeremy is a very good listener but does
he hear
anything because i would love to see
what evidence you can give of him
changing his mind
can you list the issues where he's
changed his mind be it venezuela or
whatever
okay thank you and question number three
over there
can he uh listen yup i i
just want to say that i've been watching
jeremy corbyn for many years i've been
to many of his meetings
for 10 years we've recorded him and we
know that he's an anti-semite
we've heard him we know that he supports
hezbollah we know that he supports the
ira
and my question is do the people of this
country really want
a prime minister who has that background
and who lies about it as howard jacobson
said he has told lie after lie
after lie his beloved are not not his
friends he says
this man tells porkies and he wants to
run
our country he wants to run it as a
marxist country
is that what we need okay so so thank
you very much
and i'm going to ask you that lady there
what is that lady asked about what is
the worst single saying that you've
heard
him say come here the question
microphone back please mike back to that
lady though
i want you to know very quickly the
worst thing in 10 years that you've
heard him say
jeremy corbyn refers to israel as a
racist entity that to me is the worst
thing that because what he's talking
about
he's not talking about israel he's
actually talking about jews
israel is a synonymous people thank you
thank you very much
okay uh right um
howard do you want me to say the worst
thing i've ever heard him say
yeah you haven't got the time to hear
the worst things he's ever said
but i thought when he said that zionists
have got that's to say
jews jews zionists they change around as
it suits them have got no sense of irony
um and don't study history tell that to
simon sharma
and when he said that his actual words
were
having lived in this country for a very
long time probably all their lives
they don't under having lived in this
country for a very long
how to make a section of this country
feel like aliens
is he the clothness of that ear that he
does not hear
you that you can say to people who have
lived in this country for generations
oh you've lived here but you haven't got
the part of it i have never felt
and all the jews i know all said well
that really is the end of it
whatever doubts we had before that's the
end of it if we can talk about jews like
that
then there's no hope for him and as for
this
but i could also add the speech he gave
on
on iranian tv because this is a man who
made many appearances
on iranian tv and russian tv there's a
role for god
the speech he made on iranian tv to the
iranians who swear
the destruction of israel he said i
think the bbc is a bit biased
because they seem to think there is an
argument to be made for
for the survival of israel through his
the ma the bbc is biased because he
thinks there is a
an argument to be made for the survival
of israel meaning i don't think there's
an argument to be made
for the survival of israel that's where
he stands on israel
okay and got that thank you very much
i'm going to want to identify the people
for the next batch
and bring in ash for the responses to
that does he listen
uh is he in fact an anti-semat
again i think we've answered that but
does it matter
would he be capable in downing street
of ruling in the interests of jewish
people
or would he discriminate against them i
mean i'd like to try and take some of
these questions in one big bunch because
i think the one which went unremarked on
was um by the lady with the fabulous
earrings about this rise and an semitism
and attacks on synagogues
um but just quickly in terms of howard's
um talking about this
joke is that i think it was a clunky
joke it was a joke which was playing on
more british than the british
but i find it funny that you found that
indefensible whereas you defended the
healing power of bernard manning you're
on record saying this
you were you know part of a documentary
in which you're in the front row
laughing along
bernard manning that's what i did i
didn't defend him at all you didn't
watch
carefully the telegraph the same piece
in the telegraph um said that in this
channel four documentary which is in
1997 so i don't watch it
uh i was five and it was really in
sesame street around that time
um was that you're in the front row
laughing along while he made awful jokes
about irish people jewish people and
also used their n-word so this seems
like a striking
bit of hypocrisy but one of the things i
would like to say so i want to come back
to your point about this escalation and
anti-semitism because i think that this
is something which we
lose when we zero in on the labor
party's internal processes
is that anti-semitism particularly
attacks on those who are seen as being
culturally distinctive
in some way whether that's institutions
or individuals has gone hand in hand
with islamophobia and at the same time
you've had an amplification of
anti-semitic harassment and hate
online i think that this needs to be
dealt with by looking at how our culture
reproduces hatred of those who are
deemed
to be other who are deemed to be deviant
who are deemed to not
belong here the problem is the problem
with isolating
wait give me give me a chance to respond
okay right because i did listen to you
i'm going to say thank you very much can
you please be quiet so that
everyone else can get on with the debate
thank you ash your response i'm going to
take three more questions and i would
really like not to have questions on
anti-semitism because this is a bigger
debate
tonight than just ambition i'm saying
very important
but there are question number one go
question number one thank you
um entertaining as it's been can we
maybe talk more in detail about the
economic policies that jeremy corbyn
uh so uh is he fit economically
to run the country uh secondly
uh here
corbin's mantra for the many not the few
is more suitable to a country like south
africa
in this country the many are the middle
class the few or the downtrodden
so the question he's the right
politician but in the wrong country
all right okay uh thank you very much
indeed i'm going to ask chris to come in
first on that and question number three
well as a partially jewish person i am
absolutely appalled that this meeting
tonight has been hijacked
by the debate about anti-semitism
i mean frankly
we face as has been said
this incredibly serious question
about whether we leave europe or not it
seems to me
that has to be the main
burden of what we should be talking
about and which
party let alone whether jeremy corbyn is
fit and the fact is we are being so
let down and why is it
in fact we know that the 48 52 result
was absolutely outrageous
for us to be taken forward on the basis
of something called
democracy in something so
important so why is this not being
discussed
in relation to who should lead the labor
department
and to be fair to anna she said it was
the most
important uh topic uh in the whole of
national politics at the moment
chris told me that his section on europe
he didn't have time to come on take
europe take the economy
is jeremy corbyn fit to become prime
minister
later this year or anytime in the next
three or four years well obviously i
believe he is clearly and in terms of
economic policies look we've had four
decades of neoliberalism it's
been a total failure it's completely
failed
whole swathes of our country we've seen
manufacturing jobs offshore to low-wage
economies we see
people millions of people in precarious
employment
we see our public services being hived
off to the private sector
we see our utilities going the same way
they're used as a cash cow
and we see industrial scale tax evasion
and avoidance and we
absolutely have to clamp down on that
and
we are saying that we'll be an end to
neo-liberalism we will have an economy
that does indeed work for the many
not the few we will make sure that the
tax evaders pay their way
that the faceless corporations actually
pay
their way and contribute to the public
services
and the education and infrastructure
that they rely upon so yes
we are a party for the many not the few
and as for only oh sorry
i was going to say europe just just
anywhere on europe okay well europe
listen on europe i campaigned night and
day i was up in the early hours of the
morning on the two days prior to
the vote to leaflet commuters so i
played my part and i spoke at numerous
public meetings we lost the vote
we cannot go back and have another vote
and i tell you what
if we were to go back and i think it's
incredibly irresponsible
of anybody from anna to chukaramuna to
constantly be calling into question
the decision that was taken by the
british people as flawed as it might
have been
because a decision has now been taken
whether it be 52-48
that's how democracy works and if we
continue
down this track and if they were to be
successful
in getting another referendum i fear we
would lose it
but worse it would i think precipitate
an even worse postmodern 1930s crisis
arise in the far right we're seeing the
influence of the far right and the
conservative party already
and we would be precipitating a
nightmare scenario we need
a people's brexit let's focus on that
and stop this piffle
about calling for a people's vote in the
second referendum nonsense
so no pitfall no pitfall no nonsense
if jeremy corbyn had come out really
strongly
given how effective he is we've been
hearing as a campaigner
if he'd come out really strongly for
remain would the vote have been
different
jeremy came out strongly for remain
[Applause]
let me tell you isn't it odd how nicola
sturgeon
is hailed as a great conquering heroine
who secured
exactly the same percentage of s p
voters
voting for remain as jeremy corbyn did
it's absurd it's another proxy war by
the people who are obsessed
with prison which has
failed millions of british yeah you were
given seven and
or if i said to you if you said would
you mark my speech tonight and i went
hmm
seven i'd be quiet if you gave me seven
you wouldn't
you would you'd want ten uh well i would
but i'll be happy if you get it
if you gave me seven hundred between
ourselves i think i think you deserved
ten
thank you for someone to have so few
arguments and to be delivered them with
such passion
i think it's fantastic
so what is labour's policy what's
chris's policy on brexit that's the most
the woman is right that is the most
important question because it reflects
on
corbyn's leadership remember corbyn said
we should trigger article 50 the day
after
the eu referendum do you think that's a
responsible leader
to trigger article 50 the day after the
eu referendum
they have had no policy until they've
been dragged
screaming and kicking to a customs union
and the irony of it
is is chris williamson talks about the
manufacturing sector
unless we have that frictionless trade
in the single market
you will see hundreds of thousands of
jobs will
go in the manufacturing sector so why
isn't
labor standing up as now increasingly
trade unions are doing calling for
customs union
calling for the single market calling
for an economic
outcome and finally on the people's vote
that is about the deal
and i think the people of this country
do have a right now we know
more about what leave actually means
they do have a right
to a say and a vote on a deal and
interestingly
the gmb came out in agreement with that
yet another trade union who labor's
meant to be wedded to
seeing why it's so important that the
deal goes
back to the people so they decide not
650 mps
okay just out of out of interest
hands up those people who would like a
second referendum
people's vote and hands down hands
up who still is in favor of remain
okay uh good so this is a very brexit
audience we're gonna take
three more questions now the questioners
have to ask questions in no more
than a sentence of 40 words now i'm
going to cut you off then
and we're not going to have we're going
to pick those points up can the panel
please note what they're saying
uh when they're asking and at this very
moment here
there's final voting on the motion
jeremy corbyn is unfit
to be prime minister let's take these
three
brilliant questions because there are
about 40 or 50 questions these are
brilliant questions question number
one let's go number one in you come all
right
this is for chris williamson um about
five or six
times sorry i'll stand up yeah you use
the phrase neoliberalism
yeah i want to know exactly what you
mean when you say that
got that good excellent uh number two
where is uh number two uh we're gonna go
straight through
number three over there i don't need to
be lectured by chris williamson about
anti-semitism
but my question is what government
in any country over the last 50 years
would you expect
jeremy corbyn to most emulate any
country
the last 50 years thank you very much
uh marvelous and this is the best
question of all
uh coming in here from
can we talk can we have a question on
the economy it's for everybody
and particularly chris command economies
have failed in russia
and china what you're proposing is to
take central back command and control of
our economy
and that has led to the utter disaster
so
could you comment really chris you're
much loved tonight everyone
is um wanting to spend chris chris is
here
are able to sign autographs um
ash and picking up in the any points
um it sounds strange after this evening
i'm probably filled with more political
optimism than i have
in a very that i have been in a really
long time
i think that whether you like him or not
hated or never ignored jeremy corbyn has
been part of energizing
political discussion in this country
which we haven't seen
for decades as to what country he will
probably emulate while in government i
think there are strong cases to look at
scandinavian social democracies
but ultimately ultimately the changes
that he wants to bring to the economy
are ones that we haven't seen before
because we are facing economic crises
that we haven't seen before
and the responses to those will have to
be radical and they will have to be
creative
we'll have to look at how we distribute
the abundance generated
by the automation of labor we'll have to
look at how you can have
a social housing program which doesn't
look like the big bureaucratic fair moss
of the 60s and the 70s how do you have
housing cops
on a mass scale these are the kinds of
questions that jeremy corbyn's labour
party
is dedicated to addressing and
alongside that progressive economic
platform
you will have a renewed political
culture of anti-racism
you cannot have anti-racism without that
progressive economic platform
you cannot have a progressive economic
platform without anti-racism
i'm really filled with
a sense of hope as a young person who's
locked out of the economy is
locked out of the housing market that
jeremy corbyn
and his team will be able to produce
some
concrete answers and solutions to the
problems that otherwise i've got
i think are going to result in a
nosedive and standards of living for the
decades to come we're already
looking at stagnant and falling wages
you can look at corbyn the personality
as much as you want
but take a closer look at the policies
and i think let's have another
discussion in a few weeks time
thank you ash very much indeed for that
anna i'm old enough to remember when
this country was described as the sick
man of europe we then joined the
european union
we saw then our country become one of
the most successful fastest growing
economies in the g7 that's
why we have the jobs the prosperity
record levels
of employment now i don't say that we
don't face huge challenges we know that
it's not just about brexit we've got to
get it right when it comes to
public expenditures so that we will make
sure that we deliver the great services
we need
we've got to make sure we have the
aspiration amongst our young people and
the opportunities
they all deserve these are huge
challenges that our country faces
and what we get on offer from jeremy
corbyn
are the failed policies there's nothing
new about his economic policies in
particular
and a number of you have already
identified where in the world
do you see any of those policies being
put in today
into operation and the answer is
venezuela that's about
as near as it gets these are bankrupt
policies
they were bankrupt back in the 70s and
it's true today and my final thing i
will remind you i asked you to look at
the tests of any great leader
integrity competence the ability to
inspire
decision-making accountability courage
and success
and i would argue even if you don't buy
the argument
on anti-semitism look at all the other
things that make up the man of jeremy
corbyn
apply them to those tests and i would
argue he fails on
every single one he must be one of the
most
unfit people to be our prime minister
that we've encountered in british
politics
and he's certainly not leading the
labour party
and i return to that message millions of
decent moderate tolerant people in our
country
are unrepresented and it's a scandal and
it must
change and he must go as part of that
okay um
i don't know if you've been to venezuela
but from now on you're
both going to be saying what country he
most uh
would represent um if he became leader
and you have to have gone to that
country so
chris you're to well well let me try and
deal with some of the uh
the the the questions that were raised
and i was asked about my definition of
neoliberalism
basically it's a deregulated market
capitalism
with a small state which clearly hasn't
worked as
for which countries we would kind of be
similar to
i think kind of take your pick across
western europe really in terms of the
way in which they've
conducted their economic affairs and the
point that was made about a command
economy what we're talking about is
democratizing our economy
giving people a stake in our economy
making the economy
work for ordinary people giving young
people a stake giving young people hope
giving young people a career plan
making sure we can care for our elderly
and disabled people
and rather than seeing them as some sort
of burden or a way in which we could
make money
through the privatized social care
system and as for anna's point
about britain being the sick man of
europe in the 1970s yes the 1970s
definitely had its problems but economic
growth
never ever bettered anything that was
achieved during that period and
furthermore
every single year from 1945
through to the introduction of
neoliberalism
saw a bigger and bigger proportion of
the national income going to workers
in their wage packets so if we could
replicate that once again
we could get back to the point where
young apprentice bricklayers like i was
in 1979
could aspire to buy their own home again
ash touched upon the challenge of
automation
we're embarking upon the fourth
industrial revolution
are we seriously going to sit back and
leave it to the neo liberals
or are we going to make sure that we use
the benefits
that will flow from the fourth
industrial revolution i remember being
told to get ready for the leisure
generation
in the 1960s and 70s because automation
was supposed to be
mean that would only work 10 or 15 hours
a week that is now a genuine real
possibility but we need a corbin-led
labour government
to make it happen
[Applause]
for a moment i thought derek hadn't had
come back uh for a moment we had direct
to explain who derek hatton is i
i'm a young person i wasn't around in
the 70s myself
the wonderful thing about hearing chris
williamson is i now understand what
happened did you know he runs a road
show
he goes up and down the country doing
this road show where you deselect people
i thought road shows were places where
you chose a record on the beach
but apparently not you go on to the
beach you choose somebody you'd like to
select
and chris williams says okay i'll
deselect them for you on the grounds
that deselection is such an important
part of the labour party at the moment
and i think the place jeremy should go
to to learn a lesson
is israel and he should talk to some
israelis
and maybe if they're if the country is
as apartheid as he's
successfully apart of as he says it is
which is total bladder
because it's not true in the slightest
bit in the slightest
bit true but since he thinks it is maybe
he can learn a few lessons then because
apartheid
is what you're practicing in your
country in your party
you don't want any other voices anybody
who speaks other than you
you deselect you call that a labour
party
when you think of the great tradition of
the labour party the wonderful
radical moralistic christian political
socialistic
tradition from which the labour party
has grown those wonderful men of the
18th and
19th century and it's come to this you
don't agree with us you deselect it you
should be ashamed of what you've done
to your own one straight party
how had you still got another 10 seconds
can you do that gesture again because
you should be ashamed of what you've
done
for your one straight part i've got 14
seconds
you well i give those to chris chris
well listen our party is growing
exponentially and i'm absolutely proud
of my party proud of jeremy corbyn and
we're going to transform this country
i'm sorry everyone it has been such
um uh such a dull uh quiet
debate uh here i've got now ringing in
both my ears severe tinnitus
uh from uh these people and being kicked
under
uh the uh table two and uh but i do have
the
result for you um and the result i think
shows that we know why the
f we are here tonight um
the uh for uh the motion that
who these people think that he's unfit
and there are some
uh 800 people here tonight
it was 66 and it has gone
down that's a false fact uh it's gone
down to 85 percent
uh 85 um and
against has also gone up
uh up uh from a 13
to 14 therefore we can say that
everyone's a winner no we can't uh we
can
sorry everyone's a winner uh but uh
howard uh what really i think is
shameful is that there was apparently
one person here tonight on the data i've
got
who didn't know uh but i've also been
told here they thought
they'd come to a wrong debate they
thought they'd come to a vegetarian
society
meeting tonight so uh if you want to
identify yourself
hannah kay here is in the front row and
we'll refund your money so that you
might come back again
thank you for being a great audience
thank you being a spectacular
[Applause]
panel
you